Okay, let's try this again.
>> I can speak. I speak Arabic better than
you.
>> Okay, then show me the Arabic New
Testament. Open it up. What does it say
when it says the letter to the Romans?
What's the word?
What's the word? Come on. You speak
Arabic better than me. What's the word?
>> Yeah, I thought so. So, let's come back
to the issue. Let me read.
>> No, wait there. I'm opening the the
Bible, New Testament. What does it say
in Arabic when it's a letter to the
Romans? What's the word for letter?
>> Letter is like, you know,
>> what's in Arabic? You said you speak
Arabic better than me. What's the Arabic
word for epistle? When they translate in
Arabic, what do they call the word
letter?
>> What?
>> Oh, so you just agreed.
What is a a message written by a rasool?
A message conveyed by rasool. Are you
really being serious with me right now?
But I'm I'm I like the tap dance. Go to
Hebrews 3:1 and read the Arabic for me.
Hebrews 3:1.
>> I can give you all the mistakes in
Arabic.
They've got like you know things in
English because you just denied what
even your Muslim translator Abdullah Ali
says is the meaning of and if I open up
the lexican the word means messenger
apostle because an apostle someone sent
out with a message don't teach me Arabic
or English friend but go to Hebrews
>> Hebrews 3 verse one in Arabic let's see
con artist let's see if you're going to
read it tell me what
>> go to Hebrews 3:1
I'm gonna hang up If you don't read
Hebrews 31 in Arabic for me,
>> so you don't speak if you don't speak
Arabic. Then
>> go to Hebrews 3:1.
>> Hebrews is a whole is a whole episode.
>> Read 3:1. This is now five times. I know
Islam made you dumb. I'm hoping to be
cur you'll be cured.
>> No, like no.
>> Okay, then read Hebrews 3:1 for the love
of your Allah.
>> I won't read Paul's letters.
>> Read Hebrews 3:1 for the love of your
Allah.
>> Like I said to you, I don't read Paul.
Okay, then you just Muhammad, he said
he's a because according to the Quran,
Muhammad is Paul is a true apostle. Go
to chapter 3:55. So, let's further
continue your burial. Chapter 3:55.
Thank you for just burying Muhammad. I
appreciate you because you say don't
read Paul, right? Well, prophet
confirmed Paul. I'm going to show it to
you. Go to 355 of the Quran.
>> Read that for me. mentioned when God
said, "Oh Jesus, indeed I will take you
and raise you to myself and purify
you from those who disbelieve and make
you those who follow you in submission
to God alone. Subaru to those who
disbelieve who disbelieve in the day of
resurrection." Then to me is your return
and I will judge between your concerning
that in which you used to defer.
>> Okay. What will happen to Jesus's
followers?
to follow you. It's superior to those
who disbelieve. So basically make you
superior to those who dis.
>> So Jesus's followers will be what?
>> Superior to those who disbelieve.
>> Till when?
>> Until the day of resurrection.
>> Now go to chapter 61:14. See if Allah
kept his word to Isaiam.
>> Chapter 60.
>> 61 verse14.
And you
will obtain another favor that you love.
>> 6114
surah als 61:14.
>> All you have who have believed the
supporters of God and what Jesus the son
of Mary said to the disciples.
>> Read it slowly so people can follow you.
All you who have believed, be supporters
of God. As when Jesus, the son of Mary,
said to the disciples, "Who are my
supporters of God?" The disciples said,
"We are supporters of God." And a
faction of the children of Israel
believed, and a faction disbelieved. So
we supported those who disbelieved
against the enemy, and they became
dominant.
>> Okay. Now according to these two verses,
Jesus's true followers were empowered by
Allah to be victorious and vanquish
their enemies. And how long would they
be victorious till when?
>> Today judgment.
>> Okay, thank you. Now according to Kubi
in his tabs of 614 he mentions
some of the disciples whom Allah empower
whom Allah empower to defeat the
unbelievers and spread Jesus's message
victoriously. Do you know who one of
them happens to be?
>> Who?
>> Paul. The one that you said you're not
going to read. So thank you for bearing
Muhammad.
Do you have to be by the way? Can you
read him in Arabic? No, I don't have
court to be with me. But I tell you
something like when you say about Paul,
Paul go things like not like no part of
the Bible. He started writing.
>> You're not listening. If he's not part
of the Bible, he's
not part of the Bible, you just buried
your prophet because according to your
Quran, Allah empowered the true
believers to be victorious and win. So
if Paul,
>> is Peter mentioned in the Quran? Is John
mentioned in the Quran? You see how
stupid you are? Is Abu Bakr mentioned in
the Quran? Is Omar mentioned in the
Quran? Is Aisha mentioned in the Quran?
Is Eve mentioned in the Quran? You sure
you want to use that stupid argument?
You're gonna embarrass yourself. Let
Okay, listen to my argument.
>> Listen to my argument. If these verses
are true, that means Allah empowered the
true believers to overcome the
unbelievers and they would be victorious
to the day of resurrection. So now tell
me the names of those true believers.
Give me the names from the Quran.
>> The believers are the one who believed
in him when they
>> give me their names.
Give me their names
>> of
>> of the believers that Allah made
victorious because you play that stupid
game. Well, does the Quran mention the
Paul? Show me any of the disciples
mentioned by name in your Quran.
>> Does not mention the names of disciples.
>> So then how do you know who they were?
How do you know who they were?
>> Because you're talking about two three I
tell you like we sent them two
messengers but they rejected both.
>> No, I didn't go to chapter 36. See, you
think you're smart and you're slick. Let
me repeat it again. I'm not
how do you know the names of the
believers of Jesus that were victorious?
>> There's no such as name of the
believers. These are the ones who fought
him.
>> Who are they? The followers. What are
their names? Ya.
>> There's no
who are they? I want to know who they
are. Give me their names. I want to know
historically how we know this part of
the Quran is true. should happen cuz
it's referring to an historical event at
the time of Jesus. Give me those
followers names that Allah gave victory
to. Give me their names.
>> They are no reason.
>> So how can I verify this part of the
Quran is true? Where do I go to find the
truth of this statement in the Quran?
>> So should I believe like the the gospel
now? Isn't it?
>> I didn't ask you to believe anything.
I'm saying give me the names for the
love of your Allah of who these
followers were in
>> don't use of Allah because you don't
believe in him.
>> No, I know because Allah of Muhammad is
Satan but you believe in him and you
love him, right? So if you love Allah
and you fear Allah, give me
>> Dude, you want me to hang up because now
you're jumping like a coward like you're
>> If you want to hang up, hang up.
>> Okay, get out of here then. Bye. Hang
up. Get out of here. You don't want to
have a conversation. Get out of here.
>> Don't use that game with me.
>> Okay. Don't Let's try this again before
you I send you to Mecca to kiss the
black stone like the pagan. Give me give
me the name of who these followers were
because the Quran is confirming an
historical event. So how am I going to
know if the Quran is true? I have to
look into history. Give me the
historical sources that tell me who the
followers were.
>> It is not written in the recent.
>> So then how can I find out? See I dude
my goodness.
How can I find out then if it's true?
That means I have to turn to history,
right?
>> Are you Pakistani from those countries?
Are you Jewish?
>> How can I find out their names?
>> You can't do your research. I mean,
there's not.
>> Okay. No, but do the research for me
because you're trying to convince me
Islam is true. Give me a source that I
can turn to to know who these people
are.
>> It's not written in the Quran.
>> How then am I going to know whether the
Quran has given me accurate history in
the past? What do I turn to to find out?
It's not a big story whether you want to
believe it or not. You have your freedom
to believe. Why you want to believe it?
>> Dude, my my goodness. You ended up
believing in it for a reason, right? So
you just believed it without any
historical evidence. That's how blind
you are.
>> No, because I was reading a few things
like the epist of all.
>> Oh, good, good, good, good, good. You
just said it. So you went out outside of
historical outside of the Quran to
historical inference. That's the point.
You had to go to sources outside of the
Quran closer to the time of Jesus that
showed who these people were. So who are
these followers of Jesus that were
victorious according to those sources
that you mentioned? You mentioned
Epistle of Barnabas, right? Have you
read it?
>> Epistols.
>> Have you read it?
Have you read it? Because I'm going to
give you the link right now to you.
Sure.
>> The link. Amen. Not fully. I have not
read the full read.
>> You know why you're a liar? Because I'm
going to tell you why you're a liar.
You're confusing the epistle of Barnabas
with the forger you called Gospel of
Barnabas. You see, you're embarrassing
yourself because I'm now going to give
you the link to the Epistle of Barnabas
right now. And you're going to read this
for me. Here you go. See, you think
you've done your homework. You have it,
man. Okay. Now, here you just said it's
recorded like the Epistle of Barnabas
because you're so confused. And this is
what happens when you follow Muhammad.
You confuse the Epistle of Barnabas with
the Gospel of Barnabas. But you mention
Epistle. Now, here's the funeral
services for your prophet. Here's the
Epistle of Barnabas. Here you go. Here
it is. I want you to click on it because
I'm going to have you read for me
certain snippets. Are you ready?
Here you go. Click on it. You can't even
tell the difference between the Epistle
of Barnabas, the Epistle of Barnabas,
and the Gospel of Barnabas. Now, I gave
you the link in the in the Skype. Click
on it.
>> And epis
gospel.
>> Hold on. Hold on. I want to tell you
where to read this. Hold on. One second,
buddy. One second. Hold on. Let me just
tell you where to read because you said
this epistle, right? You mentioned it.
You read it. Good. Beautiful. Okay.
Here's what I want you to do. Okay. One
second. I'm going to tell you where to
read. What chapter to read. Okay. I want
you to go for me to chapter
chapter 5. And read it for me.
Read chapter five. Read it slowly.
>> The chapter is called the new covenant
founded of the sovereign of Christ tends
to our salvation.
>> Okay. Wait, wait, wait. Reread it
slowly.
So just to make sure that I'm the right
chapter 5 it says
>> the new covenant founded on the
sufferings of Christ tends to our
salvation but to the Jews destruction.
>> Okay. Now before you read that I want to
ask you a question. Do you believe that
Jesus suffered on the cross for our
salvation?
>> No.
>> Okay. You and you mentioned Epistle
Barnabas right?
>> Yes.
>> And here Barnabas says Jesus suffered
for our salvation. Now read keep
reading.
For this end, the Lord end up the flesh
of corruption.
>> Read it loudly so we can hear you, man.
For to this end the Lord endured to
deliver up his flesh to corruption that
we might be sanctified through the
remission of sins which is affected by
his blood of
>> Do you believe that Epistle Barn said
Jesus is the Lord who offered his flesh
to corruption so that we'd be forgiven
by the sprinkling of his blood. Do you
believe that?
For this end, the Lord, who is the Lord
in here?
>> The one who offered his flesh for the
forgiveness of his sins. Who who shed
his blood. That's Allah, Muhammad's God.
Read it. It's front of you. Don't play
silly with me. It's right there. You're
right in front of your eyes.
>> Mate, mate, I don't I'm not playing
silly like, you know, you have different
culture theology approach. You have like
this.
>> Friend, you mentioned Epistle of
Barnabas. Don't change the subject. I
just use epistle to show your father.
>> In Europe, we do things like, you know,
in a in a respectful manner at least.
Okay. So we have
>> then why do you follow Muhammad? Wait,
wait, wait. Why do you follow Muhammad
when he insulted people, curse people?
Don't play this game with me, dude.
>> No, no, I'm playing games. I'm having
>> Okay. Do you want me to show you
Muhammad cursing people out and cursing
them and insulting them?
>> We can talk about
>> Stay on the topic. Read it now. Read the
Read the chapter. Read the chapter.
>> We're trying to have a healthy debate.
>> Read the chapter. Read the chapter.
>> Mate, we're having a healthy debate,
please. I'm asking.
>> You can't have a healthy debate and
follow Muhammad. This is why Christian
Prince blocked you. Now I see why he
did. If you're consistent, reject
Muhammad who insulted people, cursed
people, women, and him. Don't play nice.
Can you read the chapter? No mate.
>> Can you read the chapter?
>> One more time. Read the chapter cuz I
know you're trying to run. You're
scared.
>> I'm not running. You have to be You have
to have
>> Read the chapter.
>> Okay. There you go.
Okay. Now, for the rest of you, you see
he's a fraud, right? Okay. There you go.
He appealed the Epistle of Barnabas, not
knowing that the Epistle of Barnabas is
his burial. And, by the way, he cussed
me out and he cussed my mother out. Just
want you to know that. So, he's a fake.
So, he's the one who appealed to he
appealed to the Epistle of Barnabas. And
this is the epistle of arms that Jesus
said that says Jesus is Lord the son of
God who died for our sins to wash us by
his blood and whom the father said let
us make man in our image. Okay so you
heard that right? He cussed out my
mother. Just want your nodes there.